My son loves making things out of play dough.
Making it from scratch lets me introduce
him to a very important idea in chemistry.
If you mix two or more substances together,
sometimes you end up with something very different.
We're going to make something really special using these ingredients.
First the flour, and then the salt.
Can you mix it for me?
Putting salt into the flour like this produces a mixture.
In science, this is when two substances
are physically combined but no reaction has taken place.
I'm using slightly bigger grains of salt here
to show you that the flour and the salt are still here in their original form
and that they can be separated using a
physical process
like sieving.
What happens if you put this in there?
It'll turn blue?
Ooh!
When liquids like water and food colouring
completely mix like this we call it a
solution.
What happens if you put the oil in?
It will turn yellow.
Bubbles!
The particles in the oil are held together
very tightly so they do not mix with
water.
Oil is also less dense than water so it
floats on top.
Can you put it in there for me please?
All of it!
It feels so nice!
Let's see what happens if you take it out of the bowl
Shall we try that? Yeah!
Putting all these ingredients together and kneading them
has produced something new
This is because chemical reactions have taken place.
It would not be very difficult to turn this
back into the ingredients that we
started with originally.
Adding water allows long chain-like molecules called proteins
from the flour to stick together
helping to hold the water in place
and keepint the dough together.
Salt helps in this process by letting
the proteins stick together more strongly.
It also stops the dough going bad. The
oil coats the other ingredients and helps
to keep it from drying out.
Download our information sheet to learn more about the science of making play dough.
We'd love to see your photographs and videos of you doing this activity
and don't forget to subscribe for more
great experiments